So we've been warning about the possibility
of violence in the streets after this
election. And for me, looking at
four scenarios of a Trump blowout,
a Biden blowout, a narrow Biden win or a narrow
Trump win, the most dangerous scenario to me
was a narrow Biden win, particularly one in which
Donald Trump claims it is rigged. And that is the
situation that we are increasingly pointed to
is Donald Trump's leads have slipped away in
Pennsylvania and in Georgia as of this recording.
And we are getting in the direction of having that
serious risk of violence. Yesterday, we saw
armed Trump is showing up at various locations in
Arizona. Many of you very interested in
that story. Will Donald Trump Jr tweeted
that Donald Trump needs to go to total war.
Like many of the tweets being posted over the last
couple of days by Donald Trump and Eric Trump and
others, Twitter immediately tagged Donald Trump
Jr.'s Post as potentially misleading. But what
he said is, quote, The best thing for America's
future is for Trump to go to total war over this
election to expose all of the fraud, cheating,
dead, no longer in-state voters. That has
been going on for far too long. It's time to
clean up this mess and stop looking like a banana
republic. And of course, Twitter flagged it saying
this tweet is disputed and might be misleading
about an election. This is not what you say
when you are winning. He's tweaking out.
He's terrified because the entire family
is worried about what happens if they are
deposed. Is there are there criminal charges
in their future? Is there prison time in their
future? I don't think it's likely, but we know
that they are scared and this is really serious.
Donald Trump yesterday saying it's all being
stolen from us. Don Junior saying it's time for
total war. Remember, stand back and stand by.
This is what they were standing by for, this could
lead to significant radicalization of people to
real world violence, FOX News viewer militia
types had a plot to kidnap and murder the
governor of Michigan, Tucker Carlson, told
millions of Fox viewers that if the media
calls it for Biden when he wins Pennsylvania
without checking for fraud for two four weeks,
then it would be irresponsible. And people
need to think about what to do next.
This is extraordinarily dangerous and the terms
blood in the streets are being thrown around
it. I am genuinely scared for what the next two
weeks hold and how irresponsible are these people
to do it? And you know why they're doing it?
Because they don't care. Don Jr. doesn't care
if his tweet leads to violence. All he cares
about is how can we hold on to power? They're
looking for piles of gunpowder in order to light
a match and throw it over their shoulder as they
walk away, plug their ears and then say, listen,
I don't know, lighting matches isn't a crime.
Oh, there happened to be gun powder where they
listen to you got to talk to whoever left the gun
powder there because the lighting of a match
is not a crime. It's getting really bad. And
we're also learning the extent to which Donald
Trump over the last 48 hours may not even have
understood what was going on.
Let's discuss that next.